[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality the host of the Ken Coleman
show author of the number one
bestselling book from check to purpose
as my co-host today so we definitely can
handle your career job and work
questions along with anything else you
want to throw at us the phone number
Isle
88255 225 thanks for being there we're
going to start this hour with William
and St Louis hi William how are you
doing good Dave hi Kev how are you doing
good what's up how can we help yes I
just have a question I'm 30 years old I
graduate with my degree in computer
science I currently work in a trade
right now doing foundation repair and
I'm thinking of pursuing a career in the
military but not quite sure if it's what
I should be doing I don't I feel as
though I don't have much of an
opportunity of growth using either of
the skills that I've learned or would
like to do them long term okay so we
have two different factors there so
first I don't feel like I have
opportunity for growth uh with a
computer science degree I that that
couldn't further from the truth uh
technology is the number one industry
where we stand today and going forward
will continue to be so so the sky the
limit on technology now in the trades I
would say that's incorrect in the trades
as well but in your particular role as
foundation repair maybe that's true so
that's one narrative problem the second
thing you brought up is uh I don't know
if I want to do them long term now
that's that's that's what we need to be
paying attention to so is the military
just another option or is it something
that you've always longed to do you
you're a patriot you want to serve our
country in a specific way or is it just
another option that maybe I'll kick the
tires on because I don't want to do
computer and Technology work and I don't
want to be in the trads what is
it um I've always had the drive to do so
since my senior year of high school and
even through college but now that I've
been a working professional for this
long I I feel like I can't get the
opportunity with my foot in the door to
use my computer degree and like say
doing trades it's it's fun but I don't
I'm not giving any benefits or any
actually any benefits at all okay well
let's if I offered you a job making
150,000 in computer science would you be
would you have
joy I'm not sure complete Joy but I mean
it wouldn't hurt either well I mean what
why why not complete
Joy honestly it's money is not really a
motivator for me so back to the military
thing I thought I heard you say that
you've always wanted to serve in the
military since high school did I hear
you correctly that's correct okay then
why what's behind
that I haven't had much goal or general
direction in what I want to do so I just
kind of fall on you know whatever seems
easier okay that's not a good answer to
I've always wanted to be in the military
it's completely opposite
so um what you have to understand is is
that there there are things that you do
well those are your talents and then
there's things that you really enjoy
doing and to this point in your life I
think you know what those are so if I
interviewed everybody that knows you
William what would they say are the top
two or three things you do well and
we're talking about a skill set could be
a hard skill or soft skill what would
they say I'm not quite sure I'm not I
don't have that many talents all right
now we know what's going on so here's
where we're at William so I'm going to
give you a couple of tools that will
allow you to dive into this not under
the pressure of being live on the air
okay I'll tell you about those in a
minute but here's what's going on
something has happened to you something
has been said to you to where you don't
believe that you have anything to
offer you don't think you have any
talents and that couldn't be further
from the truth so what we got to do is
we got to get you to a place where you
begin to see wait a second I have
something that I can do well that's come
easy for me people have complimented on
this and if I'm if I'm able to get
through the pain and through the past
and see that then I can begin to realize
oh I have something that I can do well
and when we get the clues to that there
will be things that we enjoy closely
aligned if not the same thing so stay on
the line and I want to do a couple
things I want to give you the get clear
career assessment and this is a
wonderful little tool of self-awareness
I want you to take it and then I want
you to read the book from paycheck to
purpose then I want to schedule a call
Austin let's schedule to have him call
in on my show after he's done both of
those things and we'll work through what
we now see and Dave uh you know our
friend John delone deals with this a lot
too when someone feels as though they
have no worth they don't feel they're
worthy and then they have a hard time
even identifying I can do this well this
is a type of work that I can do and
contribute to the world and that's
what's going on with him yeah and then
you fall backwards that's correct you
start selecting things I'll try
right well I mean you just like take
take the path of least resistance it's
like I can't screw that up right I'll go
to the military and they'll tell me what
to do when that up right yeah and that's
not that this is um Earl Nightingale
great motivator used to say that you
take an 18-year-old young man young
woman and they've got the whole world in
front of them there's nothing but hope
there's nothing but dreams there's
nothing but Vision there's nothing but
excitement and if you're not careful how
do they select their first career choice
what their friends are doing mhm that's
right I just got on down to factory come
on down there hiring right and that's
about how much work you they spend more
time picking out a suit of clothes than
they do a career that's right and you
can fall backwards into things if you
don't uh deem yourself uh of Great Value
yeah and um you know if you're in the
technology world and you actually know
how to do
technology uh the sky's a limit yeah
you're incredible on what you can do but
you got to actually believe it and I
can't get my foot in the door has
nothing to do with the technology world
has to do with his foot you nailed it
see here's what's going on with this
young man and a lot of people that are
listening today and watching if you
don't see how you are uniquely put
together then you will never believe
that you have tremendous value so this
is really a self-awareness situation but
I will tell you that undoubtedly and I
don't want to put him on the spot on the
air undoubtedly he has been in an
environment or he's had some experiences
that has made him feel as though he
doesn't have much to offer and so
awareness is huge to begin to see
himself as somebody who can do things
well that's talent who enjoys doing
things that's passion and who is
motivated by results that's a sense of
mission and that's what's in the
assessment that we'll give him so I want
the audience to know I didn't want to
put him on the spot uh I've talked to so
many people like that on the air that
they're dealing with a cloud of
confusion when you're in that you don't
interview well yeah you can't see cuz
every anyone doing an interview looks at
that looks at that person that's using
that type of lingo and sentence
structure and they go uh-uh yeah pretty
quick it's almost as big a turn off as
the other end of the spectrum where you
get a guy if you could buy him for what
he's worth and sell him for what he
thinks he's worth you'd be rich right
you get a guy on the other side who's
all pumped up and you know really thinks
he's something he's not right and that's
the other end of the spectrum and so
when you're when you're an employee
you're doing an interview or uh an HR
person recruiter doing an interview
you're picking up on these Vibes off of
either one of these two characters we're
talking about here and uh it makes a
difference quiet confidence and courage
is an amazingly powerful thing it
changes your voice tone it changes your
body language it changes your um the
believability that you can add value to
an
organization this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your health care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian healthc Care
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly 10 billion doar in
healthcare costs chm is an affordable
alternative to insurance that gives you
the freedom and empowers you to live out
your values and you can join at any time
so find out more at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Melissa is with us in
Rochester New York hi Melissa welcome to
the Ramsey
Show hi good afternoon sir and thank you
so much for having me on the show sure
what's
up sure sir the reason why I'm calling
in is because I'm having a couple of
issues right now I Curr currently own
the home that I live in it is completely
paid off however that home is actually
my mom's home what was your mom's home
it's now
yours yes it was my mom's home it is in
my name now it is paid off however it
was originally my mom's home she lost it
and so I helped her save the home and
now it's in my name out of fear that
she'll lose it again however sir um my
mom has made infrastructure changes to
the property um without this was before
I even had the home she had made
infrastructure changes and she didn't
properly permit the house so she's gone
now a couple years with having rooms
that she created into the house that
weren't permitted and so now I'm in fear
that I may be see facing any type of
legal issues or ramifications that can
come out of the house being in my name
and her doing things to the home before
they were even in my name and so now I'm
trying to just save myself any issues
that may come out of all of this and I
want to just unded myself anded my mom
back on the property and just give her
the property to take care
of how old is your
mom my mom is 70 years old okay what did
she do to the
house she refinanced it no I'm talking
about the structural issues what did she
change she added um bedrooms to the
property so she did an addition
yes changed the square footage of the
house are they not within code well no
they had if you didn't permit you you
changed the square she changed the
footprint
right yes okay so the actual outside
structure of the home is the same it was
never changed but what she did was she
built up additional walls creating
bedrooms inside inside the original
footprint inside the original footprint
correct yeah that's why they have no way
of knowing what happened there right
correct so no you're don't have any
liability nothing to worry about nothing
to worry about there's nothing to worry
about right nothing to worry about
unless and that's why I asked theod did
she rewire the house without getting an
electrical
permit no did she replum the house
without getting a plumbing permit
yes completely replumbed the whole
house well she added a a bathroom she
added one bathroom yeah okay all right
is it done is the construction done of
reasonable
quality yes is okay I don't think you
got a thing to worry about nothing at
all I think you got a thing to worry
about it would have been better to per
minut it but lots of people do that kind
of stuff I mean that's a fairly normal
practice yeah some some municipalities
are much more strict than others I can't
tell you that you know Rochester New
York is not like the toughest in the
world or something I don't know that but
in general most people you know it's
inside the footprint she didn't change
the dimensions of the house and um you
know she didn't illegally do a trade
other than adding a bath I I I I really
truly
um I I I don't think you got a thing to
worry about and I wouldn't give her the
house back she's going to borrow against
it well and here's what's going to
happen is she's going to screw it up
then she's going to turn around and
leave it to you when she
dies and you got the mess again you're
gonna get it back this thing's a
boomerang yes and now my my one fear
right now is so the conditions of the
house the roof needs to be replaced
that's about $20,000 the driveway needs
be replaced fencing needs to be added
because she hasn't is she living in it
or are you we're both living in it right
now what do you make a
year uh right now I'm not working I
decided to put myself back into school
and I just graduated two months ago how
do you
peoplefy um where's the
money well I have savings that I use up
right now I only have about 2,000
savings
left and you have a paid for house house
is all run
down come again sir it's you have a paid
for house but it's all run down yes it's
run down and what are you getting ready
to do for a career
now I'm getting ready to go into public
safety law enforcement to be
specific and you'll be making what I'll
be making approximately $60,000 a year
okay all
right well and I currently have okay I
would not date it back to her I would
either sell it to an investor as is and
you guys go about your Merry way or I
would sit there with a plan to to
gradually do the uh repairs that need to
be done out of cash from your new
job part of this is you want to get rid
of the of all the negative things that
your mom represents by getting rid of
this
house yes sir because right now she
rents out that's that's where some of
the income is coming and she did
additional bedrooms She rents out the
bedrooms and so that income she claims
it all because that's technically her
retirement since she doesn't work I'm
sorry the house is
yours how does she run out your house
and she collects the rent y'all are
weird
yes it's only because it's only because
the house was originally Min I did save
it from her I didn't technically have
any Financial investment in it um how
did you shve it
then um I was able to um when she short
sell the house I was able to purchase it
for about $40,000 and that's called a
financial
investment yes and she has since then
refunded me that money okay um you don't
have boundaries is is b i you know I I I
I think you might be right Melissa I
actually I'm change I'm going to change
my mind right here in the middle of this
call wow I think you de it to her and
let her have it and you go have a
life and when she passes away you
auction it off don't you ever move move
in
it okay I think this house and all the
chaos that occurs around your mother in
this house uh is all a huge negative
spot for you and a clean fresh start in
criminal justice system is a a great
thing for you clean no chaos simple
little one-bedroom apartment and you
build up some cash again and uh you've
come out even she gave you the money
back that you used to save the short
sale but you can just push all of this
chaotic weirdness over to the side and
not have to worry about it anymore and
just I would yeah I would talk to a
title company and I dat it out of your
name into hers and you go move but only
if there's a clean break there yeah you
have to you have to stay your own place
you have to have your life completely
separate completely clean all the chaos
stays over there on her side of the
fence don't help with the roof anything
around this mom figure is chaotic I can
smell it in the air she's a character
mom's a character and then you're
sitting there trying to be a normal
person in the middle of this character
and that's why I called y'all weird so
um I couldn't figure out how you own the
house and she's collecting the rent uh
but now I'm starting to understand so
yeah I think it is a good idea let's
just get away from it but not because of
the
remodeling uh because of the chaos
around your mom and this is never going
to be it's always going to be the weird
part of your life until you give it a
little bit of distance and a little bit
of a boundary all right Casey's in St
Petersburg Florida hi Casey what's
up hi thank you for taking my call sure
how can I
help um so I've just been listening to
your show for about a month now and I um
understand a little bit about the baby
steps and I actually just signed up for
the financial peace uh course through my
church so wow great to get started on
that yeah um so my situation is that I
am 41 single um I have 83,000 in student
loan debt you're a doctor or a
lawyer a nurse practitioner oh good
that's even better okay so you're making
what
110 um I'm making 135 135 great I love
it what other debts have you
got um I have 8,000 in private student
Loom debt okay um 5,000 in a parent plus
loan for my
daughter and I have this is the really
hard hard to even say out loud is I have
um $199,000 in credit card debt from
medical bills um and other things okay
what we're going to do is just do what
we do in Financial Peace University
you're going to live on beans and rice
rice and beans you make a wonderful
income and as a nurse practitioner you
can also pick up some side gigs called
ER on the weekends and it pays really
well I want you working all the time I
want you spending no money no
restaurants no eating out no vac
vacations no life and now we're making
150 160 we're going to live on about 40
and we're going to throw 100 at the
student loan debt and you're going to be
100% debt free in around two years but
it's going to be two years a hell so get
ready it'll be worth it though cuz
you'll be free that's exactly how you're
going to attack this with great focused
intensity good question I'm proud of you
get at it holler if you need some more
help
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window cover ings go to blinds.com now
and save up to 50% off everything
sitewide visit blinds.com today to learn
[Music]
more
can Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today I'm Dave Ramsey thanks for
joining us the phone number is
88255 225 Rebecca is in Denver hi
Rebecca welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's
up I'm wondering what your thoughts are
on purchasing a custom tiny home
okay so my situation is I'm going to a
divorce um my daughter and I are living
in an apartment and we're selling our
house and wondering um on the other end
of it I should have between 100 and
125,000 um from the equity I'm going to
beef up my emergency fund and
then I could pay cash for a c for a
custom tiny house and my daughter is a
senior in high school um otherwise I'll
probably stay in the apartment for a few
years trying to save some more money
just kind of was wondering I know how
you feel about trailers I wasn't sure if
it was the same with the tiny houses
yeah what's your uh
income uh
85,000 a year all right and um how long
were you
married seven years I'm sorry it's a
hard thing to go through um yeah well
here's the problem with the tiny house
um
other than the fact that it's
tiny here's the problem with the tiny
house uh there is no track record out
there it's a fairly new phenomenon and
there's no track record out there that
says that there's a secondary market for
it meaning when you get ready to sell it
there's no evidence in the marketplace
yet that you're going to be able to sell
it at all and that you'll be able to
sell it um uh for a price even close to
what you paid for it so you you could
get really stuck um if they you know you
know so why is it I don't like mobile
homes well there's a long track record
they go down in value 100% of the time
okay so we have a pattern an observable
pattern and in finance things that's
what you're looking for is an observable
pattern and so it's why you would like
for instance if you bought a home in a
neighborhood uh that is way out on the
edge of town and is brand new that's not
as predictable an environment as buying
a home in a treelined street that has
been there for 20 years and is very
predictable you follow me so yes even
those two neighborhoods those are both
single family homes I'm discussing there
but those two neighborhoods give you a
predictable pattern and that's why I
would never buy buy a tiny home because
it's such a new phenomenon we don't know
what's going to happen and and we do
know this we do know this the
market is uh is nowhere near the per the
number of people looking for a tiny home
at a given moment would be way smaller
than the number of people looking for a
regular home
agreed yes so your your opportunity to
your your buyer pool that you would sell
to is very small no pun intended
so not physically small but numberers
small but the uh there's a lot of tiny
home jokes here but yeah the uh yeah so
I I yeah no I would not buy one for that
reason it's that simple it's not that I
hate on them or something like that I do
hate the I this idea that they're
presented out there as somehow the
answer to High house prices the answer
to this or that they're not the answer
you know you know not yet someday there
may be a robust Market of people buying
other people's tiny homes uh but today
there's not and so no I would tell you
don't do that I would rent an apartment
for a little while I don't think it's
going to be five years I I I think you
can go buy a home you have a good income
you got 100,000 bucks to put down so get
you a good 15year fix you you know
Denver's an expensive Market it's tough
to buy there but I would not give up on
real estate for 5 years so you you kind
of presented me three options I'm going
to be in an apartment I'm going to buy a
tiny home or I'm going to be in an
apartment and wait 5 years two options
uh and I think you're in apartment a lot
less than 5 years um but part of this is
you guys getting
your your spirits and your emotions
reset after this pain that you two have
been through you and your daughter and
uh just having a simple apartment
situation is a not a bad thing for a
year and just use that year to live very
conserv conservatively and add to the
$100,000 down payment and then talk
about maybe this time next year you're
talking about buying a home and you know
it's presidential election year maybe
we'll see interest rates come down who
knows other than the fact that they
almost always do during a presidential
election because it's hard to get
elected you pretty much give up the
White House if you give up the economy
so we kind of got that coming right
there is that and I you know I I also
think just with all the pain and Trauma
that they've going through that high
school senior daughter needs some space
and and you're in a tiny home there's no
space and her having her own you know
place to move around that senior Year
let you guys heal and get stable I think
this comes from a lot of people feel
like uh renting is throwing money away
and it's not when we're getting stable
it's not when it's patience with a plan
yes yeah spoken like a dad of teenagers
okay yes Mary is in Washington DC hi
Mary how are
you doing okay how are you guys doing
better than we deserve how can we help
yeah I was um calling in my husband and
I have just started following your
program um and you know we've made some
some I think smart decisions over the
years but we've been doing things in the
different in in the not necessarily the
order that you guys have laid out and so
I wanted to call in and check to
see um sort of a a challenging question
a moral question is should we pull back
on things like
tithing or retirement
in the short term to focus on debt it
feels odd to do that um but I know that
it's a hunk of of money so I don't know
we're just calling to get get your
thoughts and advice on that okay uh we
never tell people to pull back on their
tithe okay their tithe is off the top
its first fruits it says in Proverbs
many times and so it's the first thing
you do so if you're a person of Faith
which is what what you're indicating by
saying tithe because that's that's a a
word associated with our faith um so
judeo-christian ethic of some kind you
know whether you're Christian or Jewish
either one but that's where the word
tithe comes from so you're putting that
upfront now the rest of it is um the
most powerful wealth building tool you
have is your
income and when you give it to someone
else in the form of debt payments you
slow down your ability to build wealth
so how old are you you
guys um 40 41 okay and how much debt do
you have not counting your
home um about 60,000 on
what um
58 of it is um student loans and then
2,000 left on a car and um what's your
household
income um about 110 okay and how much do
you have in retirement
now um we each have maybe between 80 and
100, and do you have any money that's
not in
retirement uh we have a little bit in
savings what's a little bit ,000 $5,000
okay you don't have another mutual fund
sitting around or another investment
account or anything
else no no it's all sort of wrapped up
in retirement gotcha okay so what we
would tell you to do and we think this
is the short we know we've proven this
is the shortest path to wealth versus
the one you're on is we would continue
our charitable giving continue tithing
off the top before you do anything be on
a detailed written Budget on the every
dollar app the two of you are in
agreement on what we're doing I would
temporarily stop the retirement savings
and I would clean up this debt in the
next 12 to 18 months and then you don't
have any payments but a house payment
but this student loan's going to hang
around so long you think it's a freaking
pet yeah it's been around for you know
15 plus years now oh it's a fat pet
okay yeah this thing need Sally May's
got Sally May's gotten to be a toxic
bother she needs to go may my gosh yes
yes and we've gotten it down I mean no
you hadn't you still owe 58 don't tell
me you guys it's $588,000 you you you
need to attack this with complete focus
and temporarily for a short period of
time year to a year and a half I'd stop
my retirement and I would attack that
with a
Vengeance like my hair was on fire and
uh if you do that I mean you put 30,000
a year on it you'll be done in 2 years
you put 60,000 a year on it you're done
in one year so somewhere between those
two is probably where you're going to
land and I'd really dial it up and get
after it
kiddo this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear here
there's another offer you need the
Churchill Mortgage home buyer Edge super
fast preapproval and a secured interest
rate plus a $5,000 seller guarantee
gives your offer the best chance of
being accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host
today our last caller 40 years old with
a student loan that's been around
forever still hanging out with a student
loan at 40 $58,000 student loan um and
of course we are most of us aware anyway
that student loan interest restarted
September 1 and the payments will start
in a couple of weeks here again in
October so we've got um somewhere around
44 million Americans with 1.7 trillion
dollar in debt that have this uh train
barreling down the tracks at you so we
decided to help out because the name of
our company is Ramsey Solutions so we
need to give some solutions not just um
not just squawking about it so we're
going to do that tonight if you want to
join us 7 p.m. tonight Tuesday night
September the 12th we are doing a live
stream it's completely free it is me
Jade warshaw and Rachel Cruz we're going
to be talking about student loan debt in
America how we got here and how we're
going going to get out uh it'll be in
four or five hours from right now if
you're listening to us live but it is at
700 p.m. central
Time Tuesday night September the 12th
it's free just go to ramsy solutions.com
studentloans and you can put in your
email address and uh you'll be able to
give the live stream a free watch we'll
send you the link pretty simple Patricia
is up next in Rono Virginia hi Patricia
how are
you good thank you I have a question
about my
auto
okay so my question is my lease is
coming up um I went to the dealership
and the amount to buy it out is
$27,000 now um I don't know if I should
just go ahead and buy the car or get a
cheaper car and and be just kind of like
Dead free because I will still have the
mortgage you have any money
uh I do have a savings of
$30,000
okay um what is the car
worth uh 28,000 so $1,000 over the price
yeah so it's no bargain it's an okay
deal but you can probably get that deal
on a used car a lot so there's there's
nothing that says to buy this car if you
were sitting with um no car right now
and you told me you had $30,000 I would
not tell you to buy a $28,000
car mhm cuz you only have $30,000 that
would be using up all of your money you
see what I'm saying yeah so I'm going to
toss them the keys when this lease is up
and go buy you about a $10,000 car what
do you make a
year uh it depends but the minimum
55,000 it depends how much I work to be
honest yeah well the maximum car you
ought to buy would be uh 50% of your
income so that puts you at about you
know 25,000 bucks but that's too much
car because you don't have the money so
if I woke up in your shoes I would have
no car payment and be driving a very
nice gently experienced $10,000 car now
the difference in a $10,000 car and a
$30,000 car is pretty
substantial but it's not it's not like
it's unreliable it's not like it's not
safe it's not like it's any of those
things what is unreliable is being broke
what is unsafe is being broke and $2,000
with a $30,000 car when you make 65,000
is broke I wouldn't put you there so I
wouldn't buy that car and I wouldn't buy
anything anywhere near that price uh now
if you told me you had 100,000 in
savings yeah and you love this car maybe
but uh even then it's a lot of car for
someone with your income lot lot of
money tied up yeah I I I've been
shopping Dave you know this for
teenagers you can get really decent cars
uh in the10 to 122,000 range even in in
this so-called you know used car
inflationary period you can do it you
just have to swallow your pride and go
wait a second I'd rather have more money
than soall pride and you can get really
decent cars that are functional and
still in good shape it's very doable I
look all the time I got two more to buy
next year I'm a used car expert Dave at
least I'm self-proclaimed you know but I
mean that's reality well you're finding
stuff out there that's safe yes it's got
a lot of life left in it it's not filthy
trash on the I mean $15,000 car is not a
hoopie no you know that's a nice car I
just got my son Ty a Ford Explorer 2012
Ford Explorer just give you an example
$122,000 bought it from a nice local
businessman had it in his it's HVAC if I
said the name you'd know him and it was
sitting in their parking lot they've
treated it wonderfully it's in
phenomenal shape his eyes about bugged
out of his head and mine too I didn't
expect to get any something that nice at
that price range but uh it's a fantastic
car barely over 100,000 miles
wow so I me got a lot of years left this
isn't fantasy I'm not just saying this
it's it's doable yeah that's what we
would do in your shoes Kennedy is in
Indianapolis hi Kennedy how are you I'm
good how are you better than I deserve
what's
up um okay so this is actually for Ken
um more so so I applied for I'm and I'm
in a position I've been in it for a year
and a half I meet all the qualifications
to promoted to a senior position per the
guidelines that my job laid out the only
thing I'm missing is the year and a half
of in the same position I've worked for
the company for almost five years come
February but I've been in this position
for a year and a half they want me to be
in it for three but I have all the other
qualifications and they're like we're
sorry we can't do anything because you
don't have the extra year and a half so
you just have to sit there for a year
and a half before we will promote you I
don't know how to get around that I'm
doing everything extra I listened to you
a couple days ago and you were like you
know just I asked my boss hey I want to
be promoted I want to be a manager this
is what I want to do what do I have to
do to get it and she said you've got to
wait the year and a half yeah so there
anything I can do no you have to decide
do you want to be there do you want to
work there because they have laid out
for you what is required and you know
listen this is this is the tension
between patience and persistence you
know we want to move forward we want
progress but it requires patience and so
now they've laid it out very clearly for
in fact I'll be honest with you I I'm
really impressed that they held the line
on what they prefer I'm not they sound
like a bunch of idiot bureaucrats well
then there's Dave's opinion I mean
really I mean why would you the woman
the woman's been there five years she'd
be promoted at
Ramsey well but we don't know anything
about the organization she meets all the
other qualifications the only thing she
hadn't done is sit on her butt in that
one role for for a year and a half all
right so let me clarify I don't
necessarily have to agree with it I
respect the fact that they were clear
and they've held the line and they're
consistent so the point is they
communicated clearly to you is what I
was saying and I respect which gives you
the opportunity to leave so now you get
to decide do you want to wait another
year and a half or do you want to move
on so so here's the ultimate if you knew
that they changed their mind today would
you be super excited about the present
and the future with this comp well then
I love this I love the company it's just
I I don't want to be stuck in the same
role I am I want to get promoted I feel
like I've deserve to get promoted
because I have ask you this above all
right let me ask you this yeah do do you
agree with Dave that their uh that their
uh requirement is it arbitrary or or do
they tie it to actual hours I don't even
know what you do is it arbitrary or is
it
legit um what that they require three
years of
experience so in their requirement have
eight different sections and you have to
meet bu 50 50% in eight of those
sections and then the requirement is
minimum of three years in the same
position doing the same role and I have
that from like outside experience but
not three years with this company so not
three years with them okay I get it all
right I get what Dave is saying but
she's been there five years yeah I think
you should get the gig I've been with
them for five years yeah listen I agree
with Dave you should get the gig but I
at least appreciate they've told you so
now you got to deal with it I don't
think you being the squeaky Wheels going
to change their policy some people in
some companies like policy more than
they do princip big company too of
course yes guaranteed yeah it's a it's a
policy over principle they have more
rules than sense that's all they do they
don't think well wait a second this
lady's got this experience outside of
here she more than meets the require
that's not the way they think so you got
to decide do I want to be here and deal
with the way they think or do I want to
move on unfortunately that's what you're
left with yeah I agreed agree great I
mean they do have the right to do that
it's their right they own it yeah and
you know sometimes people don't agree
with stuff I do here and it's got my
name on the billing though I do whatever
I want to do that's right you don't have
to agree with it but and then sometimes
they leave because they don't agree with
it and that's an option that's an option
too Yep this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsy solutions.com and
click on the get started button we'll
help you figure out the best next step
for you based on your specific situation
again that's ramsy solutions.com and
click get
[Music]
started
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
America I'm Dave Ramsey your host Ken
Coleman Ramsey personality host of the
Ken Coleman show and author of the
number one selling book from paycheck to
purpose where he helps people with their
careers their jobs and their work and
he's going to be doing that today right
here on the Ramsey Show phone number
here is
88255 225 Louisa is with us in
Washington DC hi Louisa how are you good
afternoon so great to be speaking with
you today thank you so much for taking
my call thank you what's up all right
I've got a what would Dave do scenario
and I'm pretty sure I know what you're
going to say but I'll kind of just want
to walk through some options I have and
it's concerning my mortgage so little
bit of background um I have an arm um
that resets every November and um it
hasn't really been you know much of an
issue until recently obviously because
the rates have gone up so it is
resetting from 4 and a half to six and a
half percent joyful um yep the balance
on the loan is 999,000 I've actually
paid off 52,000 in the last year and I
am on track to pay this off my goal is
December of
2025 okay so here are the scenarios I
just want to walk through want to get
your thought um option one is just to
you know STI stick with you know stick
with the the new payment coming up in
November uh my payment is actually going
down $180 even with the rate going up
because I've paid off so much so it's
actually going down um $180 so that's
option one is just proceeding with you
know six and a half%
um and then you know would the rate
would reset you know next year option
two is a recast and I've kind of read
where you're not a big fan of a mortgage
recast um and want to get your thoughts
on this so obviously the rate would stay
the same six and a half percent um this
would require a $220,000 payment um by
the end of October and that would lower
the payment $140 a month okay um so
that's option two and then why would you
want to lower it if you're paying it off
in two years what's the
benefit well I I guess that's where I I
I think I don't I don't understand it's
like we're trying to pay it off in two
years or two and a half years right
right so why how does lowering the
payment accomplish
that um I mean it's lowering the
interest that I'm paying it's not that
would be no it's
not um if you recast you're going to
recast at a lower interest rate no I'm
recasting I'm taking it from a balance
of 999,000 to oh it would lower the
balance yeah but you could do that
anyway you don't have to recast to do
that yes I could and that's what I've
been doing is just recast all recasting
does is reset the payment based on a
longer term it doesn't change the
interest charged right right okay so
there's no benefit to you mathematically
to
recast okay given that you're planning
to pay it off in two years yes correct
and here's the other thing is that I I
don't have $20,000 just sitting around
right there's
that right exactly so that kind of
brings me to option three um and let me
let me just preface this by saying I
heard you about a year and a half ago
maybe two years ago before the rates you
know were creeping up because I was
going to re refinance and I remember you
telling a caller don't refinance if you
can pay it off in three years so I kind
of went with that model and I'm I'm on
I'm on target I'm on track to pay this
off and that that is really why I did
not refinance um but option three would
be digging into my brokerage account and
paying it off entirely I have I have
about $200,000 I'd have to cash you know
not in a retirement you have a brokerage
account sitting there with enough to pay
it off yes I do pay it off
today and yeah I knew you knew I was GNA
do that I I did I did I still wanted to
walk through the options okay so if if
you had a paid for home with a brokerage
account with $100,000 Less in it would
you go borrow $99,000 on your home paid
for home to put more money in your
brokerage
account no it's the same
thing yeah yeah I think I think I'm just
having some
let me tell you what's going to happen
all right that you don't
anticipate because I've been the other
side of it myself and with a whole bunch
of other people you do not understand
when you pay this off and you walk out
in the backyard with no shoes on that
the grass is going to feel so much
different there's going to be a level of
Peace blow through your home like a nice
cool wind that you don't even know is
coming
when you owe no man
nothing all this hand ringing you've
been doing for the last few minutes
trying to figure out what to do all
that's
gone just clean and simple you just own
your house you're weird I love
it I love it and listen if you really
hate it then go get your new mortgage
yeah but I don't think you're going to
hate it I think you're going to feel
freedom that you have not felt in your
adult
life yep and I know that from the having
experienced it myself because I don't
have any dad and haven't had for 30
years and I walk around without all of
these weights on my
shoulders and um that that a lot of
people have and I get to make different
decisions and have a different level of
calm in the middle of a storm and all of
that pay off your house Louisa please I
promise you you won't regret it but if
I'm completely Bonkers and you do regret
it you can always go get you another
mortgage and theoretically put it back
at The Brokerage there's a fear there
you could hear it yeah well no it's just
this angst of the devil I know yeah
that's right the devil I know versus the
peace I've never known and um it's I
don't know if I'm doing something wrong
I don't know if which is the correct
thing and let me just tell you man when
you get no payments in the whole
freaking
world financial
peace two words that don't go together
like Airline
service
man wow like Postal Service sorry to you
postal people oh my gosh sorry to you
Airline people I mean really I mean it's
financial piece two words that don't go
together I mean I've got money and a
brokerage I've got my emergency fun I've
got retirement going and I own my whole
freaking
house some of you need to breathe that
in and make that a
goal some of you spend a lot of calories
flipping stuff over in your head ringing
your hands trying to figure out
something when the answers are usually
pretty simple clean it up people simp
simplify
simplify that's it
simplify yeah hard to beat guys hard to
beat this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's net Suite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsay we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netw gave us the visibility into
all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us net week worked for ramsy and it
will make a difference for your business
too join the more than 34,000 customers
who trust netsuite to help make them
smarter and make better decisions and
level up their operations to learn more
get a free product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today our question of the day
for the ramsy show is sponsored by
neighborly your hub for home services
from repairs and maintenance to
Remodeling and upgrades neighborly
trusted home service providers have
trained local experts who can handle
almost any job so go to neighbor.com to
find and schedule service today today's
question comes from Roger in South
Carolina I'm a 20-year-old male
currently studying aerospace engineering
I know the Aerospace industry is very
cyclical so I was wondering if having a
one-year salary emergency fund would be
a good idea before having kids well I'm
sitting next to the guy who uh
created the concept I I don't think a
year is necessary and and I don't know
enough to understand why he believes the
Aerospace industry is so cyclical but
six months uh if you're in kind of a a
Topsy Turvy industry like that I think
would be good I I don't hate having a
one-year emergency fund but is it
necessary no with credential Roger
you're an engineer you over analyze
things your job is to perceive risk and
so you see risk everywhere
but there's not that much risk you will
be fine if you have an aerospace
engineering degree you will be able to
get a job and feed your family sometime
in the six-month period yeah six months
is fine but um and here's the other
thing the more money you put into that
the slower you build wealth the faster
you build wealth the less you worry
about an emergency fund if you got a
million dollars in a mutual fund and
$5,000 in mutual in an emergency fund
you don't have enough in your emergency
fund
but you got a million dollars in a
mutual fund so you're going to be okay
yeah you know mean So the faster you
build wealth the less you have to worry
about any of this so you're going to be
just fine Tom's in St Paul Minnesota hi
Tom welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey DAV and Ken I just want to say
starting off um your principles have you
know changed my wife my wife's life in
my life so just want to thank you guys
for your ministry thank you how can we
help yeah um so so uh so getting to my
question a little bit of context um last
month I actually called Ken uh called
Ken on his show and I was just laid off
from my mortgage loan officer job
actually working at Wells Fargo and uh I
was looking for places to basically
trying to figure out references and Ken
gave me great advice and a month later I
now have a job at a Toyota dealership um
selling cars so really exciting uh I
guess my main question is is a lot of
people are coming in they're financing
their car uh they're leasing their car s
in fact you know there's some incentive
for us to push leases just because from
our standpoint you know that creates
repeat customers now none of this stuff
is stuff that I would recommend to my
loved ones I would never do it myself um
is there am I in the wrong if I'm in a
position where I'm where I'm sometimes
selling these if if so should I consider
changing jobs or what what are your
thoughts well I don't you're not
ethically doing anything wrong this is
not an illegal activity but because you
don't believe in it we don't believe in
it either but this is about your
principles eventually this is going to
eat away at you so
shortterm uh I I I would be looking for
something to make a transition because
long term this will eat away at you and
listen you know I talk about engagement
all the time I study the data listen a
person who doesn't believe in the
mission the product the service of a
company is not going to be fully engaged
and that has a lot of negative effects
Financial opportunities for you
promotional opportunities it affects
your health your mental health and
Beyond so I think long term if I'm a guy
like you that has a strong principle
conviction that you have I would
eventually move on from selling
something that you just don't believe in
yeah it's it's not something you have to
run out of the hair building today like
your hair's on fire like you discovered
the boss had 20 pounds of cocaine in his
office you don't you don't hang out
there another day okay that's not what's
going on this is uh you know a
disagreement of how the product works
and so uh Rabbi Lapin talks about the
his book He's my good friend Orthodox
Jewish rabbi and he wrote a book called
Thou shalt prosper and um the book is
the 10 reasons that Jewish people have
had an inordinate probability of s being
financially successful in any point in
human history they tend to thrive and
why is that one of the things is they
believe that making money is an
honorable thing if you're doing an
honorable thing and uh one of the things
he points out in that chapter it's one
of the 10 things is that it's uh if
you're doing something that's
psychologically
incompatible with your belief system
it's very difficult to be good at
it and so you you know back that's
another way of saying exactly what Ken
said and so yeah I'm completely aligned
with what Coleman is saying here if I
were in your shoes I would say I'm going
to give myself 60 days and I'm going to
be somewhere else MH um because they're
the the they are going to sell car
leases because they make more money on
car not because of repeat customers but
because they make more money on car
leases than they do on the actual sale
of the car and they make more money on
car leases than they do if they do a
regular Finance plan with a bank and uh
they make more money on car leases than
they do just about anything else it's
the one of the most profitable parts of
the entire Auto industry now and so it's
massively profitable for them this paper
is amazing and so they're they're not
only going not going to to not stop it
they're going to push it because it's
where they make their money and so
that's how it is it's like there's a a
series of Articles have gone around the
last few years that if you work at
Victoria Secret selling uh small
underwear right you you have to sell a
certain number of Victoria's Secret
credit cards or they will not give you
hours oh okay because they're in more in
the credit card business than they are
the small underwear business right right
small underwear is there just to get you
into the credit card debt interesting
into big debt small underwear big debt
there it is so there you go that's how
that's a great slogan you you to you to
box that one up and sell it you anyway
yeah that's so but if you if you want to
work there in that store in the retail
store uh you're not going to get ours
you're not going to be promoted if you
don't sell credit cards even if you sell
a whole bunch of small underwear and you
don't sell any credit cards you're going
to be on the street they they you know
but that's the business they're in they
know where their money is coming from
they know what the profit centers are
and they're going to drive you that way
so then you've got to decide as an
employee are you going to plug into that
and I think you've already decided oh
sure Tom I think he's already on he
already decided and just once permission
is this silly no it's not silly at all
no it's smart Brian is in Jacksonville
Florida hey Brian welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave how you doing today better
than I deserve what's up oh glad to hear
it um I have a question for you um I'll
give you a little background information
on myself um I'm 40y old I have two kids
my wife's a stay home mom we own a town
home we ow we owe about 55,000 left on
it uh my wife has some savings around
60k and I'm debating whether I should
use that money to pay up the house or if
I should invest it um like in an IRA or
something for the future um but the
thing is we're in a small town home and
we're looking to get some a little bit
more a little bit more space for you
know for the family cuz kids are sharing
a room I got a boy and a girl when are
you when are you
mov we're not moving at all yet we just
we like to get another property because
we like to have what mean is two years
or a year or 10
minutes oh it probably be next couple
years three years pay it
off pay it off today okay today the
reason I asked is my financial advisor
tells me not to because he says my
interest rate in my home is going to be
less than what I'd be making in the
stock market that's why I
figured guess what he didn't make a dime
when you pay off the house he makes a
commission when you invest the money
with him I understand that hello okay
ding ding ding ding and I didn't make a
dime either way so you do whatever you
want to do but if I woke up in your
shoes I'd have a paid for house now you
need to get yourself on a budget and you
need to sit down with another financial
adviser that's not giving you stupid
butt advice and get you an IRA started
and get your kids four get your kids 529
started and let's get some investing
going and get yourself on a budget with
your wife and the two of you working
together let's get detailed and dial
this money stuff in man cuz it's kind of
feels like you're Loosey Goosey running
out here just trying to figure this out
as you go and you need to dial it in and
make sure every dollar is barking every
dollar is doing what it's supposed to do
so getting the every dollar app getting
Financial Peace University do that kind
of stuff but uh if I woke up in your
shoes I'd pay my house off today dude
just like that no
question the this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumps
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America if you like what you hear around
here you could help us out and we'd
appreciate it click the follow button
the Subscribe button the share button
share the show share a link tell people
where you're listening on talk radio or
TBN or whatever it is spread the word
about the show and leave a five star
review they're very helpful all of those
things the share the like the uh
subscribe the follow all of those things
really push the show to the front of the
algorithms and cause people to find us
and it doesn't cost you a thing and we
would appreciate the help thank you very
much Trevor is in Salt Lake City hi
Trevor welcome to the Ramsey
Show thanks for having me Dave I really
appreciate it sure um I grew up watching
grew up listening to your show with my
parents so huge fan of yours well thank
you I got a qu I got a question for you
um regarding um either reinvesting in my
business or purchasing a home and I can
give you a little bit of information
about it so I'm 23 years old I'm getting
married in a week wow and I thank you
good for you
congrats thank you um between me and my
fiance we have about $50,000 in our
savings account uh we have no debt um my
business has about $75,000 in asset
um as well as I have about $25,000 in
Investments mutual funds CDs stuff like
that um and I'm just wondering with your
expert opinion what I should do if I
should reinvest in my business um to
continue to grow it or whether or not I
should look into purchase purchasing a
home at how much do you need to reinvest
in the business and why um so the reason
I'm reinvesting in my business I just
bought a new skider I do
landscaping um I've been able to pay
everything cash trailers equipment um I
just got a new skit and I'm looking to
purchase a second truck um I have three
employees um so looking to have a second
truck for them as well as a new trailer
um and just upgrading some of our mowing
equipment and stuff like
that okay if you spend that money you're
going to spend what 20 30,000 bucks
correct and what does that cause you to
make because you spent that that you
wouldn't make if you didn't spend it
okay so this uh I'm anticipating this
year to make back 80,000 um that's after
uh taxes everything um and I'm
anticipating if I can get that
reinvestment um I can make an additional
20 to 30 um so you can make the money
back any year next year um yes probably
you spend 20 or 30 you make an extra 20
or 30 as a result correct okay and
sounds like you got
$75,000 um correct and that's in
equipment and you make uh trailers no no
no you you have 75,000 cash you have 25
in a mutual fund and 50 in your account
right uh yeah approximately all right
and uh what does your wife
make um she makes about 40 a year and
you're going to net on your business
100 uh no I'm anticipating 80 this year
I reinvested quite a bit this year I
just bought the skider about two weeks
ago um so that ran me a little bit and I
do owe um the only debt I have is I my
father who um was gifted me 15,000
towards my skider I bought so I'm going
to pay him back was that a gift or
alone uh alone more or less well that's
an interesting piece of information for
a guy for 10 minutes has been telling me
he was debt free you're not debt free
you owe your dad 15
grand no you're not going to invest in
your business you're going to be paying
your dad back I'm I will pay it off in
the next month no today you have the
money in your account right now you
shouldn't have taken it from him in the
first
place you got 50,000 bucks you need to
borrow 15,000 from your
dad correct I just wanted to keep some
money in an emergency fund where where I
am self-employed I just and getting
married I wanted to be able to have the
money shouldn't have bought a
sker if you need the money if you need
the money for an emergency fund you
shouldn't have bought a skid steer but
you bought one now and now you got a
loan and now you got to pay it off I'd
pay that off today uh
and then what I would do is get married
and spend the first year of your
marriage piling up cash for a good down
payment on a house and after you've been
married a year you will make a different
purchase than after you've been married
a week it's a different house it takes a
year of being married to know how close
to your mother-in-law or your
father-in-law who loaned you money for
skid steers that you want to live how
close do you want to live with these
people yeah it takes a year to figure
that out so um it's a joke but not
really yeah I I was going to say a lot
of truth of that the other thing too is
is there I would be challenging myself
how can I make an additional $5 $20,000
a year over the next year of my business
without spending 20 to 30 you know get
Innovative um and and and especially in
that first year of marriage he was
already worried that's why he took the
loan out from his dad I believe yeah so
Trevor you need to quit buying toys for
your business that you haven't done a
careful Roi on because you're not going
to get an Roi on this skid steer that's
bull crap you're not going to make
enough on that thing to justify having
purchased it you would have made you
would have been better off buying mowing
equipment to expand your operation than
than with the skid steer so quit buying
business toys that don't have very fast
large
Roi stop it I had a friend of mine
that's in the building business and he
bought a skid steer now I bought a skid
steer the other day too did you really
yeah there's one out at the farm for but
I bought it for no reason at all except
have the money it's a toy you like
moving dir well I got my grandson in my
lap digging up stuff that doesn't even
need to be dug up all right so this is
embarrassing this won't surprise Dave at
all but you guys are throwing skid steer
around skid steer this skid I had to
Google it real quick James a bobcat it's
a bobcat I bet I would have know it's a
bobcat on tracks it's pretty cool
looking machine if it's on tracks it's a
skid steer right so basically you papa
Dave got his own real life Tonka it's a
toy yeah that's exactly what I did it is
it's and good for you yeah it's fun cuz
your grandson thinks that's really cool
my God it's a giant there is no cooler
Papa Dave in the world than one with a
skid deer so what I'm hearing is live
like an onl so later you can dig holes
for no reason at all yes to make your
grandson happy that's the dream of every
grandfather hey every four-year-old's
dug a hole for no apparent reason and
every 64 year-old apparently is going to
do the same thing you never get over it
I was going to say live like just so the
public knows I'm not anti-skid steer
okay I'm just saying
but from a business
perspective don't buy stuff that you
can't Roi quickly every and I got to
tell you here's an interesting thing
working with uh people on our trade
leadership very few women do this in
business it's kind of a male thing yeah
it's a male stupid thing it's toys and
they do it they do it with they do it
with computers right the guys that do
all this equipment stuff in here M I
have to constantly go no we don't need
another one right good God how many
microphones do I need to own
seriously boys collect toys man there's
just something about it and I I ladies
they they're very careful but often
times I have to get them to go the other
way it's hard to get them to do the
actual investment they need to do right
to to because they're conservative on it
but very few women in business collect
toys like boys do and you know what's
interesting I'll bet you can prove this
they're much more resourceful as well
think about the mom who always makes the
science project happen under the wire
you know with a couple of straws you
know a rubber band here it's like you
can build that business that landscaping
business without that new truck you
can't you just got to be Innovative and
that's where Innovation comes from is
when we have a lack of resources Craig
Grell talks about that a lot yeah in
fact he he's the one that it was
mind-blowing I think I interviewed him
years ago when I was hosting on trade
leadership it's one of the best thoughts
on Innovation that I've ever heard is
from Craig Rochelle yeah it create a
lack
creates necessity to become creative on
how you're going to do it if you can't
do it any other way and so that's why
your dad did you no favor loaning you
that money right so that's the thing so
all that to pick on you Trevor because
we love you and we want you to win so
pay off your dad today uh get a little
apartment and uh set up house and
concentrate on loving each other not on
stupid real estate deals for the first
year of your marriage and after you've
been married a year and saved up a
little more money above your emergency
fund and you're truly debt-free and the
next time you tell somebody you're debt
free make sure you are uh
then uh then from there you pay you put
down with an a good strong down payment
on a 15-year fixed after you've been
married a year that's what I would do if
I were in your shoes congratulations on
the marriage this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thanks for hanging out
with us America this is the Ramsey Show
we're so glad you're here hey guys uh
George camel and the every dollar team
are hosting a free live virtual training
for your budget yeah you're going to
learn how to find more margin in your
finances to spend without guilt and to
make a budget that actually works first
one is happening September the 19th at
12:30 Eastern Time spots are limited you
can pick one with George uh Jade warshaw
is going to be doing some I think Rachel
Cruz might be doing another one too so
uh all these budgeting webinars are
completely free go to every dollar
com/ budgeting and we'll help you get
started with this stuff all right here
we go Josh is in Orlando hi Josh welcome
to the Ramsey Show hey never grow up
especially if you can afford it right
gentlemen that's right there's the plan
what's up man okay so I have a pro and a
cons so here's my dilemma and I'm
actually so I'm trying to get as debt
free as I possibly can I have uh 17 No
about1 19 $20,000 in credit card debt
and then that's my primary and then my
secondary is my auto loan which I'm
about 11,000 upside down um And in
regards to my credit card um I have
18,000 in RSU uh shares for my company
and then I have $7,000 in a traditional
IRA wanting to know if I should uh use
my stock to my use wanting to know if I
should use both to pay off my credit
card debt I would not use an IRA I would
use your
stock okay and the reason for not using
the IRA penalties taxes okay leave those
alone and I would quit adding to the IRA
and I would cut up the credit cards and
never touch the stupid things again get
a debit card do not even own a credit
card okay 100 100% And then what about
the ra to where
I cash it out I have it in a savings
account you already
have yeah I uh well I did I did the
transfer or I did the the part of the
work but I haven't fully transferred it
to my my personal savings
account when did you do
this uh I did it last Friday to where it
was effective for me to utilize
today okay uh well you've got 60 days to
undo it without penalty and so I'm going
to get go to ramseys solutions.com and
click on smartvestor and find a smart
Vestor Pro in the area to help you undo
it and get it back into an IRA before
you get hit with the penalties and the
taxes
how much was in that you said there's
only like 7,000 in the account though
right yeah it was only it was only seven
yeah so you're probably only going to
lose three or 4,000 bucks but that's
still a ridiculous I mean you're paying
40% interest effectively to get the
money fre you up I would not do that I
think it's a good practice for you to
learn to leave that alone so let's roll
that back into while you're in the
60-day window back get your an IRA set
up with a with a smart Vestor Pro and
um then then start your um I'm sorry
then cut up your credit cards and pay
them all off and then you still got to
clean up your auto loan that's your next
thing so beans and rice rice and beans
no adding to any Investments of any kind
and we're completely focused on clearing
this debt that's the next process there
so good question open phones atle 8825
5225 Tyler is in Jacksonville Florida hi
Tyler welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave how's it going better than
I deserve what's up
yeah so I got a a little bit of a
dilemma here with u some in-laws I guess
give you a backstory I'm married uh
moved away from home and or I guess I
said in-laws but my my parents um moved
away from home and you know they're my
mother's not in a great financial
situation um she hasn't been working um
and and has some tax issues from a past
business and she's asking to borrow some
money to make a house payment and um you
know I feel led to um but I'm also
trying to talk to her in in the nicest
way possible to try to sort out a longer
term plan than you know make a payment
and then what do we do next month and
what do we do next month uh my
siblings uh aren't as financially
capable to to help so I feel like how
old are you Tyler falling to me what was
that how old old are
you uh 28 how old is your
mother
um
57 okay on what planet is the 28y old
supposed to take care of the 57y old
that was too trifling to do it
herself it's not your job man it's not
your
job yep and I bet your wife isn't happy
with this
either um no no what do you
um combined we're making probably 250
260 you're making bank aren't you good
for you okay what is your mom doing
nothing calling Tyler for money she not
working at
all no not no not currently uh well take
me back when when when was she
working um it's been a while um she she
had a housing housing company quite a
while ago and why is she not
working
um um not a there's not a good reason I
guess I don't think so either okay so
you giving her money is not sustainable
because you were correct in your wisdom
when you observed that you're going to
be doing it again next month and next
month and next month and next month
because you're enabling her bad behavior
yeah instead what I would do is come
alongside her and say Mom mom I'm going
to be your biggest cheerleader I'm going
to give you some suggestions and some
help and show you what to do so you can
straighten this out first thing we're
going to do is we're going to get into
Ken Coleman's book uh from paycheck to
purpose and we're going to get you a job
and a career and then I'm going to put
you on to every dollar on a budget and
you're going to make money and pay your
own bills and you're going to like
yourself more when you do that I am not
going to pay your bills mom but I will
be here for you you I love you and I
will help you figure out a way to pay
your
bills and she's not going to like that
Tyler because she likes doing
nothing yeah yeah I think that could be
the case yeah she's GNA get angry with
you and she's going to become a travel
agent with for guilt trips which is what
codependent people do when their enaer
Cuts them
off yeah yeah I'm sorry this is going to
be tough but you're being very wise I'm
not trying to just be mean to your mom
I'm disrespecting her I'm disrespecting
her because her behaviors are awful but
I'm not trying to be mean to her she
needs to change her behavior so that she
has a quality life she's 58 freaking
years old there's nothing wrong with
this woman she could get a job and pay
her bills instead of mooching off her
28-year-old
son and so she it's good for her she's
going to like herself better all the
other brothers and sisters are going to
like her better um everybody's going to
be a lot happier when Mom gets her crap
together am I missing
something no no I think that's right I
just yeah kind of what you said just
trying to figure out the the best way to
go about it without you know being mean
I guess you're not being mean when you
don't give a drunk a drink it's not good
for a drunk to have a bottle of Jack
Daniels it's not good for a heroin
addict to be to be loaded up with Heroin
it's not good for them they don't like
it when you tell them
no but it's not good for them this is
not good for your mom loving your mom
well is helping her get a life that is
not filled with chaos A Life That's not
filled with uncertainty and A Life
That's not un that's not sustainable and
it doesn't have any
dignity and so um now again I don't you
you're not being mean now she's going to
tell you you're being mean that's so
mean you have plenty of money what's
wrong with you Tyler I raised you you
can give me a
little that's what it sounds like yeah
that's exactly what it's going to sound
like coming back at you that's called a
travel agent for guilt trips she's going
to pitch one on you I'd be more worried
about upsetting my wife than I would be
upsetting my mom and I think that's what
this is going to come down I would be
worried that I'm doing harm to my own
mother who I love there's that too and
when you support the misbehavior you're
doing harm to them enablers are not
helpers they're cowards who won't say no
that's what they are don't be a coward
love her well enough that you help her
for real hel her and if you want to put
her through Financial Peace University
you call our team will give it to you
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey it's Ken if you love The Show
and want a deeper dive on your money
Journey we have a Weekly Newsletter that
gives you trending and helpful articles
and tips on following the Ramsey Way go
to ramsy solutions.com today to sign up
for our newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality is my co-host today the
phone number here is
88255 225 thank you for joining us Robin
is in Phoenix hi Robin welcome to the
ramsy show
hi thank you gentlemen for taking my
call sure I am going to retire in about
three years at
76 I have no mutual fund and no
401K my question is should I buy or rent
at that time at
76 okay how would you be able to buy if
you don't have any
money yeah well I've got these I've got
time so currently my income is 4500 a
month 2K is going to rent 2K is going to
student loans and five and I spend 500
on um daily on debt living you know
living expenses you you're 70 years old
and you have a student
loan yes yes I haven't p off yet but I
will pay it off it expected to be paid
off in March of
24 okay what's the balance on
it 12,000 wow so I'm paying 2,000 a
month on that 2K 2K month all right I
I'm really curious how you end up with a
student loan at your age how did you do
that well that's called paying the
interest i i p paid the interest only
for a long time so what's a long
time um
since since 2020 since 2005 I guess
that's when I graduated you graduated in
in 05 so you graduated 20 years or 18
years ago and you've been paying and
your degree is in
what or that that particular degree that
I've got some more since that time but
that particular degree was in
Communications okay all right and what
do you do for a
living I'm a Quality
Inspector okay
wow all right
um the the thing that runs through my
head is this uh obviously you at
retirement have to have monthly money to
pay uh an electric bill and buy
food and uh provide shelter
okay uh the largest line item in your
budget for the rest of your life if you
live to b95 another 20 something years
is going to be um
housing and if you're renting your cost
of housing is going to go up every year
because rent always goes up does that
make
sense yes if you buy at least you're
locked end to what you're going to be
spending on housing from this point
forward so buying is good having a paid
off home by the time you get there is
even better and of course having a nest
egg to live on so do you have a pension
in the background of this or are you
counting on just Social Security to feed
you no um I'll finish the rest um so
right currently what I have is a
universal life policy that has a cash
value approximately 9,000 in it I'm
reluctant to cash it out because it has
a long-term care Rider of a of 50 months
on it at 4% so that's going to give me
uh 15 about 1,500 a month just for that
now as I share um at the End by the time
I retire I will have a approximately
$500 in pension and 2500 I'm guessing
2500 in Social Security which you give
me 3,000 and and you have no money in
savings at all my,
$1,000,000 okay all right I want you to
cash the universal in and pay the
student loan down and let's be done with
a student loan very quickly let's get
that in the background as soon as
possible so we can try to accomplish a
couple of these other goals which is
housing
and start to build some kind of a nest
egg over the next 3 years so basically
you're going to live on beans and rice
for the next 3 years while you throw as
much money towards housing buying a home
and as much money towards a nest egg as
you can
throw and both of those are going to be
better moves than a bad Universal policy
so we've got to get the student loan in
your rearview mirror to pull that
off get the student loan in your
rearview mirror build an emergency fund
and then start saving for a down payment
while you're putting at least 15% of
your income or more into retirement and
I want you to save as much as you can
save for retirement while putting down
as much as you can put down on a house
and and when you do buy a home I want
you to buy a very modest a very
inexpensive
property I am more concerned that you
have basic shelter that is locked in on
its monthly cost than I am you having a
home that you are necessarily thrilled
with okay that makes sense yeah I want
to stabilize I'm trying to stabilize
your future that's what I'm that's my
first goal your luxury or your comfort
are secondary but stabilizing the
shelter aspects over your future next 20
years is really what I got to lean on
and uh
wow wow well the the good news is I
think you can actually make a pretty
good dent in 36 months on this if you'll
be very
focused
um I think that might be one of the
oldest St student loan debt callers I've
had it it's it's mindboggling I'm
sitting there listening to that and
because we're having the student loan
live stream tonight uh it's absolutely
free uh Ramsey solutions.com 7M Central
8 Eastern it's important to point out
that she is and I don't throw this word
around lightly you know this Dave she's
a victim of this cultural message that
has said if you get a degree you're
going to get a raise and sometimes
that's true many times it's not and she
kept getting
was in Communications and I'm not in
Communications exactly she's in quality
assurance and so you got to be careful
these degrees don't come with jobs you
still got to go out and find them get
them and perform them well and I I'm not
I'm not trying to be unkind but there
are so many people that still believe uh
you go through a layoff at 45 or at 50
you go I got to go get more education
maybe but probably not probably not yeah
not at the cost of sitting at 70 years
old St student loan debt no and see
that's the exchange that makes me so
angry about and let me just be honest
let me be an equal opportunity offender
folks both sides of the political aisle
are in the business of student loans
it's big business it's a lot of money
and no one's talking about legislation
or regulation to stop it to stop it and
to take on the unbelievable inflation in
the world of tuition is not doing a
service no you people in government are
not helping that's right the population
you are harming the people that you're
call called to govern it's a hidden tax
Dave and and people are getting filthy
stinking rich off the backs of people
like her and it's really does need to
stop it really I mean seriously would
somebody grow a leadership backbone and
send it to Washington
DC this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Dr John delone has a brand
new book coming out called building a
non-anxious life you can pre-order the
book right now for $20 and you'll get
$75 in bonus items nearly half the US
population says their lives are affected
by anxiety stress burnout it's
everywhere but here's the thing anxiety
isn't actually the problem it's the
symptom the problem is we're unsafe
disconnected healthy living like we have
no say and what happens next and in this
book Dr deloney walks you through six
daily choices to recognize and break
free from A Life That's spinning out of
control it is amazing this book is
selling like hot cakes too and we it
comes out technically October 3rd if you
pre-order you get $75 in bonus items
which is includes instant access to one
of Dr John's talks newest talks smoke
fire and freedom that is a great talk
and also you're going to get the ebook
and the audio book Ramy solutions.com
building a nonanxious
life Christopher is in Corpus Christie
Texas hi Christopher welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hey DAV Ken thank you for having me
on sure what's
up so give you a quick backstory I'm
recently engaged our wedding is in June
I have a full-time job making 34,000 a
year I also go to school full-time to be
a radiology tech
I have no debt and I have an emergency
phont of 20K me and my fiance are on the
same page about not going into debt for
the wedding and not spending more than
5K on our budget for the wedding I
recently made it to step four but I'm
confused if I should be investing 15%
while also saving for a wedding and
bouncing out a
home no you ought to be saving for the
wedding and for your education until
you're married don't worry about a home
and don't worry about retirement right
now okay okay you'll get you got time to
get to both right now you need to get
married pay cash for the wedding and uh
even if you Bo beef up the budget a
little bit that's okay your budget's not
out of control on this wedding and um
make sure you get through the school and
pay cash for all of it so you need the
margin in your life to just be piling up
cash right now until
June right yeah let's let's worry about
it retirement and worry about buying a
house a year or two from now
okay so I should just be saving for the
wedding and for your life yeah just pile
up money right now I want you to get I
want you to get your education finished
I want you to get married lower lower
stress on both of these with a big old
pile of cash and then when you get out
and the wedding is over if you've got a
little money left over that's your head
start start towards your emergency fund
and towards your down
payment but you're there's no don't
don't you're putting too much pressure
on yourself to try to do all these
things at
once
okay you got time man you got time how
old are
you I'm 24 you got plenty of time you're
gonna be okay Christ I can hear your
brain you're processing what Dave's
saying but it's it you're something's
got you hung up what's going
on nothing I just you're just goal
oriented yeah I guess you could say that
but I I started school late so uh I just
I'm doing my Basics right now and my
remedial courses so I feel like I kind
of started late in the game so you feel
like you're behind yeah you're not yeah
you're not you're not you're you're way
ahead because you actually know what you
want to do that's right and you got and
you're running down a very clearly
defined track your plan you laid it out
perfectly in just a few moments on the
air here in front of 20 million people
that that's impressive I mean you really
that's a great job you're doing a whole
lot better than it feels like you're
doing you're going to get to the other
things I'm not saying don't do them I'm
just saying don't worry about them now a
year from now two years from now we'll
worry about those right now pay cash for
the wedding finish your degree pay cash
for that pile up money it's all you need
to do right now that and that's plenty
that's plenty making
34k that's a big enough task as it is
yeah you can do it all but not at the
same time and I think that's pretty much
true uh in any area of life so you're
going to be okay and give yourself a
break I there's I can feel him beating
up on himself a little bit I'm behind
I'm behind yeah no you'll be okay you're
not the fact of the matter is with our
plan you're going to catch up with a lot
of people you're probably by March yeah
but you know why he's a tortoise and
he's focused and the Tortoise always
wins that race every time you're exactly
right Jeremy's in Houston hi Jeremy
welcome to the Ramsey Show hi thanks for
having me sure what's up yeah so my
primary question today uh and I probably
just need to hear you say it is trying
to work out how much house I can really
afford because when I start to look at
the numbers I I begin to feel like maybe
I'm going a little bit crazy and then it
just kind of spirals into should I ever
even think about buying a place or
should I rent
forever well that's a false narrative
you don't have to rent forever that's
not a real option you know that that's
just drama queen right well no oh so I
don't mean to sound dramatic actually I
don't necessar but I mean that happens
we have a little drama all of us have a
little drama in our head and that one's
that when you spiral out like that
that's the little drama queen in your
head I mean you know you're not going to
rent forever and you know that's dumb
because rent goes up every year so
renting is a good short-term plan but
it's not a good long-term plan you
already knew that
right I I sort of I sort of knew that
but I didn't actually feel that renting
was necessarily I don't mean it in
negative connotation oh it's negative
it's not a good idea long term I'll give
it to you negative it's here's why it's
negative it's not because it's a class
status thing it's because your cost of
housing goes up every year for 45 or 50
years you're going to pay more every
single year if you rent and and that's
that's a death nail to your finances
versus if you own the value of the home
is going up and if you're making a
payment on a fixed rate 15year that we
tell you to do the payment is locked in
the only reason it would change is taxes
and insurance but it won't change
otherwise and so you've locked in the
largest line item in your budget which
is housing and it's going up in value
versus nothing is going up in value when
you're renting longterm and it and your
rent goes up every stinking year the
largest line item in your budget takes
up more of your money every year so you
don't want to do that long term but you
may want to do it for a year or two
while you get some other things done
like getting out of debt and getting
your emergency fund in place and and
then um let me just tell you uh one of
the things you experience when you learn
to live debt-free is is that you are
living like no one else so that later
you can live and give like no one else
and when you live within a reasonable
Budget on housing there's going to be
people around you that are buying a
nicer house on a 30-year adjustable rate
mortgage maxing themselves out where
they can't breathe and they're taking on
a house payment that is crazy as a
percentage of their income and and they
don't make any more than you make and it
looks like they're winning they're not
winning they're destroying themselves
and meanwhile you're over here uh in in
a much more modest property feeling like
you're losing and the reality is you're
winning does that any of that sound
right no it does sound right and and you
know the numbers make me feel a little
bit crazy because I feel like I earn a
pretty good living my
situation I make after taxes about 140
Thou after taxes after 401K about
140,000 a year okay well we say say put
a 15year fixed rate no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay and that's
not counting 401K that's just taxes
coming out of your take-home pay so
what's your take-home pay not counting
for a1k and a 15-year fixed rate
interest rates are higher now than they
were this time last year obviously uh
the good that's the bad news the good
news is that that um you know well
there's a shortage of housing so we're
still seeing house prices go up but you
can find a house you probably can get a
seller to give you some atten right now
inventory is really low but um which is
holding the prices up but the um but if
you can find a house you know if you're
out of debt and you have your emergency
fund you have a good down payment you're
going to buy something more conservative
than your peers no question about it
yeah but again it's not it's it's the
long game that's the definition of
winning is not don't follow your broke
friends right it's not how fast you come
out of the gate it's how you finish and
and got to remember that it's so you're
not making 500 a year you're making 140
a year I mean it's a lot of money it's a
lot it's double the household income
average but it's only double it's not 4X
and it's not 6X so you know average
house price in your area plus a little
that's what you're going to be getting
this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsy
Solutions on the debt free stage Nick
and Laura are with us hey guys how are
you good how are you Dave better than I
deserve where do you guys live San
Bernardino California oh fun welcome to
Nashville and here to do a debt free
scream how much have you paid off
223,000 I love it and how long did that
take 99 months 99 months look at you and
uh your range of income during that 99
months we started at 71,000 and ended at
195 very cool what do you'all do for a
living well I am a homeschool mom and I
also do real estate on the side mhm and
I work for the County local government
there okay very good well you guys are
doing well so 99 months 223 is this your
house this is everything Dave 1 to 7
paid off the house everything look at it
weird people yep I mean you live in
freaking San Bernardino California and
have a paid for house yes this is a big
deal what's this house worth little over
600,000 I bet it
is I love it congratulations ding ding
how much you guys got in your
Investments for retirement so forth uh
we have about 150 in roths and about 200
in a pension all right so that puts you
at millionaire status doesn't
it baby steps millionaires right on the
line anyway yeah really close if we
throw in the furniture we're there yeah
all right there's not much Furniture
Dave way to go guys congratulations how
old are you 42 42 42 and a paid for
house and basically C baby steps
millionaires I'm so proud of y'all thank
you tell us the story what happened 99
months ago how'd you get connected to
this ramsy stuff well we uh I listened
to you when I was younger um probably
when we were both younger Dave um and I
was doing good and and uh we were moving
in the right direction I worked for a
bank and we went South we went on the
borrowing Trend and uh we borrowed
everything we could we wood burning
stoves credit cards everything else you
can do somewhere along the lines we just
started going negative every month every
month we were you know we were losing
money we were just not saving we were
just going red red red red red until one
day I realized I couldn't pay couldn't
put gas in my car without putting on a
credit card felt like a loser felt like
a pretty bad father because we had just
had uh two beautiful girls and I kind of
remembered everything I listened to on
the radio went back and and uh restarted
um in our
mid-30s and then we suffered a lot over
the last 8 years and here we are so MH
MH mhm so Laura he walks in and goes uh
this isn't working what' you say I said
okay well how do we fix it and he said
oh well there's this Dave Ramsey guy and
he has this plan and we're going to have
to cut everything I'm going to sell my
dream truck and I said oo hard
pass I don't think so that sounds
terrible actually you know I had two
babies and I I didn't want to do it but
I I wanted to support my husband and so
I did it for about nine months without
my heart in it but I did it you know to
the letter and then one day we were
sitting at the dining room table and we
paid off our car and I looked up and I
said oh my gosh this could
work this amazing and ding ding light
comes on it came on and I started
listening to the show and you know it
was Game On from there my heart was in
it and then it it was different you know
from then on yeah wow wow so it took
nine months of you kind of dragging her
along huh yeah and then she goes okay
wait a minute that gum this stuff is
yeah okay I like be something here Nick
I picked up on the word suffering which
was a little bit sarcastic but yeah yeah
but I I think he's actually there's
probably a lot of Truth to that and and
and I want people to hear it's not easy
how difficult this was for you guys but
how it feels on the other side so give
us a little window into what suffering
even sarcastically meant well I always
joke that Dave Ramsey ruined my life
yeah there's a whole there's a whole
internet channel on
that but the truth is I mean you're
going to see your friends and they're
going to be buying trucks and they're
going to be drive driving side by sides
down the road and and they're going to
be having a lot of fun and there's going
to be a time where you have to suck it
up and you have to say I'm going to get
some and I'm not I'm going to say no um
I I think for your normal working family
you have to pay a price um if you just
if you just wander through um you'll
wander right into debt just like every
all the Joneses and you'll be comparing
yourself so I think there's just a time
where you have to have discipline and
you have to say hey this is hard but
it's the be best thing for my future for
my girls you know for for the rest of my
life and so that's where where your
temporary Pleasures I think we um we had
to put aside for a minute and we had to
focus on our goal which took a long time
took eight years so what's the dream now
42 and you guys are debt free house and
everything how does that change your
vision well our first dream was to come
to Nashville to check it off the Box
baby there you're there one down yeah so
next scream yeah I watched a lot of Deb
free screams and I always thought if we
make it we're going yeah I like it I'm
glad you're here yeah I'm so proud of
yall it was good deal so what what is
the next big thing yeah for me you know
the next biggest thing is to set up my
girls for um a success you know in a
just a better PL platform to build off
of than I had I'm from a single wide
trailer even though it's in California
um and I just want better for them so
for me the the future is trying to build
for them and then us enjoying our lives
a little bit more yeah absolutely and
and really being an opportunity to give
and and affect people in a better way
yeah well congratulations I guess Dave
there's probably a nice truck in the
future though I would hope I think he's
he's earned it yeah maybe a side by side
he's a millionaire 42 yeah me come on
come on pay cash for it get you a toy
yeah that's good that yall should you
should enjoy some of this and you should
give some of it and you should use some
of it for investing and uh building up
the future and changing your family tree
and you will so very very well done very
proud of y'all what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is I
think that it's avoiding lifestyle creep
that was something that I feel that we
did really well over the8 years you know
Nick had a lot of promotions and a lot
of pay raises I had a few commission
checks come in and they pretty much went
all to the mortgage and that was hard
when you see other people it's
unrewarding it's very unrewarding and it
it's it's hard after a while and you
just say oh I just want to do X YZ
whatever it is and we just didn't we
just kept saying no you know we want to
pay a price to win and and over the
course of the eight years we spent the
first four years in baby steps one
through five and you know 345 felt like
it took a really long time to get
through we really just kind of crawled
through those and those were you know
hard slow years and then uh we paid off
180 in the last four years so it really
kind of picked up at the end and that's
well your income changed during that
time the income changed everything
changed we were we were working together
and the snowball really got going it was
it was really neat to see that way to go
you guys congratulations thanks we did a
tracking process as well we kind of
bought these hurricane lands and we put
some smooth stones in them each Stone
was $500 so at the end of the budget
meeting at the end of the month we would
you know see how much we could put in
towards it and we would bring the girls
in and we'd each put a rock in and
sometimes we only put two and sometimes
we put 15 you know but it was it was
something that we brought them in for
and we would talk about you know why are
we even doing this and what is dead and
why is this important and so bring them
up let's introduce them what are their
names and ages so I got two of them here
oldest is is Sabrina youngest is Cassidy
MH great hey we've got the living give
box for you the baby steps millionaires
book which is what you've done
congratulations The Total Money Makeover
book and a Financial Peace University
membership for you to either enjoy or
give any of it just our way of saying
thanks for you to come and people buy
that and give that stuff away all the
time so thank you guys so very proud of
you Nick and Laura Sabrina and Cassidy
San Bernardino California
223,000 paid off in 99 months making 71
to
195 baby steps millionaires at 42 count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
are you ready 3 2 1 we're dead
free
yeah oh you got to love it man oh man
those little girls have a mom and daddy
that changed their lives yeah well done
that's grownup stuff there boys and
girls
this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Laughter]
show
[Music]
our scripture of the day Proverbs 12:15
the way of a fool is right in his own
eyes but a wise man listens to advice
Tommy Lort says the only problem with
success is that it does not teach you
how to deal with failure Joe is with us
Joe is in Cincinnati hi Joe how are you
I am fantastic how can we help all right
I've got a question I've been pretty
intently saving uh to buy a new Bronco
even selling my early Bronco and through
my intensity and focus I've actually
saved up enough to pay off my home and
now I'm struggling do I continue on with
my plan to buy my Bronco or pay off my
house wow that's cool those Broncos are
cool so what do you
make uh about 150 what's the Bronco
cost uh it's 56 okay and you can pay off
your house for a car guy you pay off
your house for I've got a couple other
ones yes you have a couple of other
cars yeah I've got a an old classic from
my father-in-law and then a early Bronco
that I've also had for about 35 years
that the value has increased on it also
oh yeah those things are through the
roof yeah that's fun
um
H well it's a simple question that you
have to answer for yourself I don't
think anyone else can answer it for you
what do you want more a new Bronco or a
paid off
house and um I'm the other side of all
of that um let me just tell you this too
it's not it's not a Permanent Choice
it's which one do you want first yeah
because if you buy the paid off Bronco
then your next goal is you're going to
pay off the house and you make good
money and you're going to pay it off
fairly quick right yes or if you pay off
the house if you pay off the house you
don't have a house payment um and now we
can save like crazy and buy a new
Bronco so I mean my guess is is that um
two years from today you've accomplished
both goals
agreed yes so just which one do you want
for the next two years because the other
one's going to wait 18 months to two
years yeah I'm also struggling because
I've drove junk for years uh and even a
free car to keep it going just so I can
do something I'm struggling spending
that much money thinking of spending
that much money on a vehicle now it's
always what I thought I wanted when it
comes down to uh letting it go for that
I don't know uh you're not getting rid
of the other two Classics right no okay
good I was got to say I love the old
Bronco more than the new one but this is
your money yeah oh I I wouldn't make the
trade I'd keep those two and then abut
add the new one to the mix the new one's
a cool car it's it's a neat car um are
you driving something that you're not
proud of right now is he's driving he's
driving one of those Classics aren't you
no right now I'm driving about a $8,000
car I upgraded last year from my freb
junker uh so I upgraded uh in meantime
to save up for Bronco I've just been
able to save up sooner than I thought
what's the uh what's the balance on your
house
exactly uh
72,000 and you have 56 in the Bronco
account or
what uh just in my general savings uh we
actually have about uh I think 70 liquid
right now not counting our emergency
fund what's in the emergency she fun uh
we keep about 20 in there and it's
normally low but i' retire military so
I've got a pension for good pension that
comes in monthly
so I love the car I love the Bronco I
think they're cool cars I don't own one
of them but I think they're a very cool
car I can understand where you're coming
from having said that I personally would
wait 18 months to buy the new Bronco and
I would pay off my
house uh but the point is you're going
to do both within 24
months and you need to have a game plan
to do that it's just a matter of which
one goes first that's the only choice
we're making we're not making a choice
of Bronco versus house we're making a
choice of which one comes first in the
24mth
calendar and that helps me that helps me
make the decision to do the house does
that make sense yes and then then you're
going to feel a little wiser spending
this much on on a car than you feel
right now you feel like you're over
doing it a little bit right now because
that house is still dangling out there
and if you do the house first and the
Bronco second the Bronco is not going to
come with as much guilt yeah and if if
that older Bronco is pretty slick I'd
get rid of the $8,000 car sell it drive
the sweet Bronco around if you want to
upgrade you you've worked hard I get
what he's saying he's like I've been
driving crap for so long and now I kind
of want to drive something nice but I'm
with you that house is going up in value
the Bronco he buys will not no no no
it's not I know the old one did but
you're not going to keep this one 45
years it's not going to be that's
correct the thing so and it's not uh
1,800 bucks which is what you paid for
the other one right exactly right back
in the day or whatever whatever it was I
would be driving that old Bronco around
if it were me I I it depends on you
don't you don't want to mess it up you
don't put miles yeah I get it not a
daily driver Joe's in Cincinnati Hey Joe
what's up
oh that's it's wa a minute that's we
went back to I just I screwed up yeah hi
hi Joe thanks guys all right Brian is in
Los Angeles let's try that hey Brian how
are you hello sir I'm doing great thank
you for the time to be on here today
I've been a big listener to you guys for
a while now and because of you I got out
of Deb a couple years ago but um like
what my question today is uh I'm married
I have two boys we live in Los Angeles
County and my question is
uh we make a good income here and um
however we're very unsatisfied with the
quality of life here just the school
values the crime the homelessness and
all in all just the unchristian society
so we're considering relocating to
another state um such as either
Tennessee or Idaho or a few others um
the issue is that um our my projected
income would probably be cut close to
being in half why what do you
do so I'm a police officer in LA county
and with overtime uh I usually bring
around 140 to 150 a year and the same
salary in those areas are are are a good
bit less maybe like 60% of that but you
you're at you're comparing overtime to
no overtime also yep it's not half but
it is in in your field it is
substantially less yeah but it's also
worth just kicking the tires in other
states you know what would a an Atlanta
metro situation that's not the greatest
thing in the world but it's the cost of
living would be less than La look at
multiple States in a region to kind of
see what your opportunities are how long
you been on the
force uh that's another thing 12 years
so does that qualify does that qualify
you for moving into like a a highway
patrol role in one of the states because
those do pay a lot more than the state
you're talking about I I would likely be
able to go into any type of law
enforcement field in any other state but
just comparing it to California just it
truly is a significant not necessarily
how much
on this and I'm going tell you why I
covered this story recently the
Fraternal Order of Police uh they are
having a hard time recruiting police
officers you understand why I don't need
to get into that and there's a great
opportunity right now for you with 12
years of experience in Los Angeles
County I think you need to do more
research and see what your opportunities
for uh transfer would look like and then
growth and Dave makes a very good point
may even some signing bonuses available
yeah and moving into a State Police role
uh in another region of the country
could be really lucrative and that would
not necessarily be a pay cut then yeah I
mean you move into a Bureau of
Investigation in one of the states like
Tennessee TBI or something like that um
but I would get out that's the heart of
his question I would get out if I felt
the way that you set it up to Dave and I
I would get out I think
you're um moving but I think you've got
to do a little bit more work on the
career side so that it isn't as big a
cut as you perceive it to be correct
because that what you're outlining at
first blush is true I mean if you
compare it to an outlying County or
something like that in uh you know in in
a Texas or Tennessee or what Florida
whatever you might you might uh you
might see that big a cut but there's
ways to get into a Metro situation
there's ways to get into State
situations and with your experience you
might move in move up several
um pay levels uh in one of those States
and actually come out fairly close and
there's overtime available everywhere in
your world tell you what high school
football games and church on Sunday
morning everywhere everywhere police
everywhere hey man we appreciate you
stay safe out there that puts this hour
of the ramsy show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ
Jesus
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsey Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsey Network app in your
favorite app store
[Music]
today